this is from here in Doha Qatar the
World Cup Richard keys and Andy Gray
were the famous faces of Sky Sports
Premier League coverage for a generation
and English football became a global
sensation they became household names
but they lost it all in a notorious
Scandal over sexist comments made off
air about a female assistant referee and
they've since moved their careers and
their lives to here in Qatar I spoke
exclusively to them earlier in their
first UK TV interview in a decade since
it all went down
why did you say yes to me
well it's quite simple
your Piers Morgan you're the governor I
kind of like your style yes you know I
think it would it be my mate Pierce's
style very much yeah I think
so we had a chat and it wasn't as you we
might suspect it wasn't a done deal when
we were asked but I gotta say to it so
that I'd like you talk to people we are
as my great friend late great Ray
Wilkins would say we are a tad or we're
a tad bruised yeah and so therefore we
withdrew entirely
um from from engaging with the British
media
um and and we've largely concentrated on
the opportunity that was afforded to us
here we've had an absolute ball for a
decade
um the other thing that I thought you
you were very fair about peers was your
attitude towards this world cup the
country friends that we've made in the
time that we've been here just to start
with the fact that World Cup's here you
guys have lived here for the last decade
what do you make of the way that
particularly in the UK there's been this
narrative about Qatar they shouldn't
have the World Cup it was one with
corruption there are all these problems
with LGBT rights to me these are all
legitimate concerns I agreed but I also
think there's been a lot of hypocrisy I
don't remember this outcry it's as
intense as it's been in for such a long
time around Russia four years ago I
thought and that was four years after
they've invaded Crimea right and with
exactly the same record about human
rights when it comes to
lbtqbt and so on and so on so I do feel
there's a lot of hypocrisy there's a war
raging in Yemen right
um but but my my view on uh yes there is
a lot of hypocrisy
um I none of us condone what what Putin
did has done and and would wish to do as
far as his Excursion into the Ukraine is
concerned but but I think that resonated
more in Europe because
white faces were being seen in in
distressing situations if the color of
the face is different it doesn't quite
resonate to the same degree
unfortunate as that is it's true so here
here we've had different Wars at
different times that we we've had to
come to terms with and they haven't
necessarily
made a a line of Copy in the UK so
yeah all of the things that have been
mentioned
we understand and I think the country
here more than any in this part of the
world understands but I think it was you
that made the point when I was listening
the other week if you accept the
principle that a World Cup is coming to
the Middle East and it should where are
you going to play it if not counter
right and by the way for the same
reasons you then go and play it in
Africa which has many of the same issues
to go to India do you go to China I mean
what about four years from now in
America
I love America I've lived there on and
off for nearly 20 years but you know I
don't agree with some of their laws done
laws some of the state laws about
abortions
um I wonder if people will take the high
moral ground about America's laws I
doubt they're willing with the same
ferocity I don't think it'll get a
mention peers because again it I I refer
you back to what I just said about
listen a lot of what the criticism level
that this country has has boarded if not
has been racist it has been shocking
please let me tell you about you say
overnight and and in all honesty this
country 11 now there's no resemblance to
the one I moved into 10 years ago
in what way and the way it has changed
it's its views its laws
um the kefala that used to be in here
that restricted people I think from
traveling and whatever that's that's all
been gone they're modifying everything
in that respect and they are trying to
move on but as you said they're doing it
slowly and maybe that's not to
everyone's satisfaction maybe it's too
slow if you were being critical what
would you say what would be your biggest
criticism
I think all of the issues that you can
give me another couple of golf courses
yeah yeah
it's factors should be taken as
seriously as they have been but you
can't use them to consistently whilst
changes taking place that's a at the
pace of the Qatari government again
users shouldn't be dictated too but
either West and and whatever we believe
to be
valuable and important in life you know
you you have to follow this no it's been
a slow process perhaps in some areas too
slow but progress has been made
virtually every day since we came here
and Andy's right it's a totally
different country the one we moved to
and it's a very enjoyable place to enjoy
let's get to why you came here right so
the last time many people would have
seen if they don't watch your
commentaries now will have been when you
were riding unbelievably high at Sky
Premier League was on fire you guys were
the front men for it life was good you
were Superstars really of British TV
especially in football and then back do
you recognize any of that yeah just me
nice to watch you guys I love you guys
right you know you're an integral part
of my football watching life yeah and
then Bang
do you regret saying the things you said
albeit they were said private of course
listen it yes
um
I questioned whether
a young lady from Coventry my hometown
would know the offside law as she made
her debut
um the female lines were yeah yeah
um
I on air
because I was not sure who her father
was actually on air as we went to the
kickoff said and we also have a female
assistant we call them these days
um Good Luck to her Sean I don't know I
may have gone to school with her dad
she's from my Manor so all the very best
to her she made a number of Errors first
half
that I was insistent we didn't show
nor did we she got once absolutely spot
on uh the goal that scored against
Liverpool I believe when I spoke to her
the following day
she was great she said hey come on now
did you rang her to apologize yes of
course and she accepted the apology more
than acceptable she said I expected this
last week it's just a bit of fun come on
Casey it that I'd never really come
across that word Panter she said oh come
on it's just banter and and that I
suppose stuck in my mind and I said no
no I said Sean this is really serious
now it's got a life of its own I I have
to make this an official apology on
behalf of myself and Andy who's in
commentary now she went well right okay
I'm I'm waiting so I did and then she
went oh by the way
couple of things first half that you
didn't show thank goodness for that
thank you so we're not in that business
you know so yes in isolation those
those questioning whether she knew the
offside law was was
unacceptable without anybody honestly is
sports
television at the time very few people
would survive all their private
conversations being made public I don't
think that's that's not because
everyone's awful it's because the banter
that you alluded to earlier was very
prevalent management I hate that word
and I'd never as I said I'd never used
it but Sean said to me I expected it
last week oh come on it was only about
and I suppose that was in my head and at
the time when you're on the defensive
because you can't get your head around
what's going on it's an extraordinary
place to be you know you've set the dogs
on many in in in in a different role
well I've been on receiving interviews
you've also been on the receipt so I've
been yeah I I know what it's like it's a
terrible place if you had your time
again yeah would you have done anything
different in the way you responded Yes
what would you have done I would have
accepted quicker than what people were
saying to me was was uh accurate and I
would have understood sooner that what
what happened shouldn't have done
um but you you
you're not in that place and
um but I've said many times to friends
given the same circumstances again of
course I would have gone to things
differently but you you also have to
then factor in mental health which I I I
think people too quickly dismiss less so
now than they have for the first time in
my life I I found myself in a very
difficult place I just I couldn't get my
head round it appears it it didn't at
that time seem to be so significant to
to start the forest fire that was
engulfing us alluded to the fact that he
had Suicidal Thoughts at one stage yeah
that would be serious yeah that's
serious I mean you talked about it I I
had a wonderful life
[Applause]
fortunate lucky uh I played 17 years as
a footballer it was glorious best
especially as in my life
I'll give you that yeah okay okay and uh
and then went to what uh in the sport I
love for a new broadcaster it was about
to revolutionize football in the way it
did and had 20 years there
so I suddenly found myself at a really
dark place
the house surrounded by people
and I knew I had
done something wrong of course I did
but I couldn't compute it
and my head was gone and it hadn't been
to my wife I don't know what would
happen I really don't Rachel is amazing
wonderful you really you were that low
yeah I was closely going down the garden
where I used to have a pool a pond down
at a garden with a little bottle and a
few pearls and I would I would have had
that
I was up at one day I was that bad yeah
but
I mean that's so horrific
people who normally will probably think
yeah your kitten because you two nobody
can see it in your face now even as you
read think about it again total it's a
very emotional thing to relive it
I couldn't work it out
and you had done wrong but I thought you
know for two weeks I couldn't get out of
the house
um we were just surrounded by pressing
TV cameras and Crews and uh
and your family was what saved you yeah
Rachel and the kids
and Pals
you know friends people who
you learn who your friends have pierced
with things that happens to you and I I
think we both did them did you know how
that how low Andy yes I was there too
same oh feeling suicide oh peers really
you have no idea it's it's you know
mental health it
he's right you can't explain you look
back now with a clear head and a clean
you go what come on what are you
thinking you know but when you're in
that place and and he's right you
couldn't the only I used to have to
leave my house from the from my back
Garden I would walk to a local Nursery
that was close by I got a taxi and I
flew out here actually because uh NASA
Al khalifi who I'd worked for earlier
2008 and he wanted me to join then and
of course I should have done when I was
too comfortable I should have taken this
off if I didn't so he he called and said
look nobody's talking about it out here
why don't you come out here but then the
heat got too much and I felt I had to
back away for us because it was going to
bring too much attention to this country
and they didn't need to inherit our
problems at that time so so we put it on
a burner so in in effect I lost two jobs
and we lost two jobs in in two weeks
um one of them of our own volition but
no it's a it's I think it was wrong that
you lost your job
well I talked about how it made you feel
let me ask you can I ask you then can I
can I turn that on you yeah because I I
would like to know do you think it was
wrong we lost our jobs well it's
interesting you know when I've looked at
it all again it feels to me like an
overreaction by everybody because I
think that you you made fulsome
apologies I know Karen Brady for example
who is one of the bosses at West Ham and
when one of her players got caught
kicking a cat around horrendous video
came out she said everyone deserves a
second chance of forgiveness
and yet I remember her reaction to when
you two were sacked and it was a
different reaction and I felt there was
a real kind of uh Feeding Frenzy to do
you win which with hindsight now looks
like it was overdone but mainly because
you didn't say this on air and I do
think that everybody
anyone who was
who had all their private conversations
put on to public domain I'm not sure
many people would survive it it went
some opiates I mean you've been in more
green rooms probably you could count and
had conversations regress off off make
and and if half half of the things that
you talk about were run the people would
be horrified private conversations
aren't what they why they're called a
private conversation Andy who let you
down most in the world of football that
you would have expected to defend you
when you look back at that time yeah
lots of people are there any of the
stick in your mind I wouldn't want you
to name too many of them my real friends
were there without a shadow of a day and
I knew I knew who they were
um I mean Andy Townsend we've talked
about Andy he was one of my neighbors
then and I was sitting there on the
kitchen one day just head was all over
the place the next minute the gate's all
big on this motorbike
rider comes right down the drive he's
got an extra he's got an extra helmet
and he's under his arm he comes
screeching in and it's Andy takes it out
off he's like
what you come on I said what I'm getting
you out of here I said no now you're not
I was I was he said yeah yeah come on
put this helmet on we'll get up to the
gate and then we'll do a runner I said
no I can't but that's the kind of friend
that was there but there was there were
lots of people that I looked after
appears very space and various things
that I never heard from and I've never
heard from probably in 20 years let me
ask him and have you guys
I think every every bloke right we're
all how old are you now if you don't
realize I'm 50 next year 50 I plus but
how do you guys
I'm I'm 65 because and I am 67 in two
days and I'm 57. I think every I think
every bloke has probably gone through a
little bit of reevaluation in recent
years about what is appropriate and not
appropriate in terms of how you act what
what you say have you guys since what
happened to you have you gone through
that process yes and I sometimes look at
what you've got to say on different
matters and I think to myself no peers
come on because if if we are to find a
balance then we have to over balance in
One Direction in order to to get back to
the middle because for too long men have
had everything in their own way and and
we're looking to try and find Middle
Ground if we're not going to do that
just by us we in my view we've got to go
here and we have to accept a lot of the
things that irritate you particularly I
mean drag them to the center ground and
then we might find a better battle
because I know at the moment I announce
I've done this interview we all know
what's going to happen there'll be
people on Twitter why are you
interviewing those sexist dinosaurs
there's dinosaurs rule the world for
about 300 million years
to those who think that's what you are
because of what happened 10 years ago
what do you say to them talk to anyone
who knows me
really I can't defend myself it's easy
to defend myself you know but that would
be wrong people know me it appears
people who have been my friends and talk
to my family anyone who knows me ask
them and if they turn around and say to
you yeah he's definitely a sexist then I
would be very very surprised so I I
I said if you were offered jobs again in
the UK would you go back
um my primary I am deeply loyal to the
company that I work for and with
um I think there is a process at which
now I would be able to yeah engage yes
um but I I there is no suggestion of
that being the case
um but yeah I listen I
I find it extraordinary honestly because
in life things happen for a reason I
believe I wouldn't wish upon any but
well I might one or two exceptions but I
wouldn't wish on the majority
um what we went through but I as a
result have lived a a wonderful life I
mean I feel and I might be completely
wrong here but just from the interview
you gave to the Telegraph and from just
things I've picked up
and even today actually that I think the
maybe you've come to terms with what
happened
better in the sense that you're ready to
sort of leave it I feel with you Richard
I'm correct if I'm wrong there's still a
lot of anger about what happened no I I
just don't I'm resentment no I don't
think that's necessarily true I'm I'm
very comfortable at the place we're in
um but I I I will I will always carry a
little bit of anger in my back pocket I
don't think that's a bad thing if if
that is to be used
um by way of motivation then then I I'm
very happy with that as well but no
there are a number of it's it's it's
Instinct peers it's it's it's something
that you would do you would want to know
what happened I can't that's how my mind
is if you let bitterness eat you up it's
not bitterness in this way
how would you categorize it it still is
a back a back pocket yeah full of anger
yeah that's all when you think about it
yeah and and I do for him when I see my
mates out there as distressed as he was
talking about it yeah I feel protective
and then and then that stirs you know a
little bit more of me to get on the
front foot and that's that's how it's
been stopping a quick football questions
I can't not ask you give them away at
the World Cup in your backyard but can
England win the World Cup
they can they can will they
that's a different question they're
capable yeah what will it depend on
now his ankle looks dodgy if it's not
England who do you fancy who do you
think one of my one of my favorites a
really strong I thought Belgium would
make a real impression here I also think
Portugal with my old buddy Christiana
you think he was right to do the
interview with me no why not at this
time of his career I thought it was
badly timed I didn't think he needed to
volunteer for the aggravation that it's
brought him
um where are you I would have said to
him listen I'm very very keen that you
sit down and talk with me but let's get
you sorted out first because we don't
want to taint the Legacy we don't want
you leaving Manchester United under a
cloud and there's no reason Roy Keane
left after a similar Outburst on Manu TV
and he's revealed
I don't think a few months problems with
Eric 10 hard and the coach he had never
heard of before that ran right I don't
think he's gonna make any difference to
the Legacy do you think he'd say
Manchester United fans will see yeah
let's forget everybody's one of the
greatest players I've ever had and in
terms of what if they what if they have
a view of Ronaldo the same as you've
just suggested public do still of us
it's gonna be a long time you know what
Cristiano said to me you're never going
to please everybody so you may as well
be true to yourself that's true anyway
guys oh you see what we've done we're
now interviewing you
know what it's great it's great to see
you
enjoying your own in your own uh I've
enjoyed my time here and I'm glad you
guys have enjoyed it and I hope this
interview goes away to you know well
thank you people realize what you've
been through and we'll end his restart
appears and it's kind of you to offer
the invitation for us to come and talk
to you and I know one of your objectives
when you took this job was to uncancel
people and if you've played a role oh I
think so don't you I don't think you
should be here
I don't think almost anyone should be
irrevocably canceled I agree I'm not
sure what more you can do than show
remorse so you wish you hadn't said
those things but they were said
privately a lot of other people were
saying similar stuff at the time I heard
them in some cases right in the football
world and I think that the reaction was
overdone you're very kind to have given
us this opportunity good to see you
thank you good morning are you going for
a swim how much
good to see you